manchester is a city on hold in a region
in limbo from merseyside to tyneside
almost 15 million people across northern
england are waiting to hear
if lives and livelihoods will be locked
down
if local measures come restaurants and
bars here will pay a high price
forced to close on evidence they dispute
the chancellor has promised a new
package of support for workers wages
if lockdown comes but wouldn't say if it
will
i'm announcing an expansion of our job
support scheme
specifically to protect those jobs of
people who work in businesses that may
be asked to close
if that happens those workers will
receive two-thirds of their wages for
the time that they're unable
to go to work i hope that this provides
reassurance and a safety net
for people and businesses in advance of
what may be a difficult winter
business is already down 40 per cent at
wood simon says the promise of support
is undermined by the uncertainty my
initial reaction
is one of dismay and no one as far as i
know in the country would go to work for
66 of the wages
employers certainly can't top up the
other 34
with no revenue if we are locked down
that impacts revenue supply chain
morale everything it's it's something
that is devastating
hospitality's fortunes have fluctuated
with government advice first we were
subsidised to eat out to help out
then came the 10 pm curfew now doors may
again be closed
manchester's nighttime economy advisor
says it may be permanent for some
i'm a positive person pull um and i
can't sugarcoat this
i'm afraid to say that sadly we are
going to see
mass closures mass redundances because i
think
what was announced today was probably
announced a bit too late
even without new lockdown measures the
economic outlook for autumn and winter
is
bleak gdp grew by just 2.1 percent
in august and what growth there was was
driven by hospitality precisely the
businesses
that could now be shut down consumers
are thin on the ground in birmingham too
and so is confidence with case numbers
rising
they too could face new restrictions for
venues like the symphony hall
forced to close since march the
chancellor's support
offers a little hope we have an
absolutely viable business model here
we we directly employ hundreds of people
thousands more in our supply chain we
just need support to get us to the other
side of this crisis
musician louise might have played the
symphony hall in normal times
but self-employed and unable to work
there was nothing
from the chancellor for her i would
simply welcome
parity with employed people
it's not true that we have been treated
with parity or received the same levels
of support
as other people
[Music]
there are no easy options in this crisis
we may be lamenting the economic damage
as well as lives lost for months to come
paul kelso sky news